Professor John Merriman:
Okay, today I want to do two
things.
I'm going to talk about the
centralization of the French
State and the question of why
Paris--and that's kind of fun to
talk about--and the role of
Paris in centralization,
and the particular role of
Paris in French economic,
political, social and cultural
life.
And, then, in the last twenty
minutes I'll talk about why this
sort of strange man,
the former "miracle baby," as
he was called after his birth,
the Comte de Chambord,
did not become King of France,
Henri V, and why France ended
up a republic,
and how;
and, that has something to do
with the centralization of the
French State.
Now, anyone who's ever spent
any time in France at all,
who's ever waited in line in a
prefecture in Privas,
or Agens, or Paris,
God forbid, we wait for hours,
will realize that the role of
Paris and the role of the
centralization of the French
state is unique in--at least in
Western European history,
over the long run,
and it still is.
Despite all of
the--Mitterrand's plans for
decentralization,
and the creation of regional
councils,
basically France remains the
most centralized state in
Western Europe,
and the role of Paris in French
life does not have an equivalent
in other European countries.
Now, let me think about that;
let's think out loud about that
other statement.
Think of other countries.
In Spain, obviously Madrid,
Madrid is the capital but
Barcelona is terribly,
terribly important,
and was always a much more
economically important city than
the kind of command economy that
was Madrid.
Or, if you think of Berlin,
you think of Germany,
a unified Germany or in the
Federal Republic before German
unification,
Berlin was terribly important.
It is now again the capital but
Berlin is balanced off by Munich
and by Frankfurt in some
important ways.
So, if you take a little
country like Scotland,
Edinburgh and Glasgow are two
major cities.
Or, if you take England,
for example,
people came to care in very
major ways what people in
Manchester thought because
Manchester becomes the capital
essentially of the north and the
economic center of production.
Or, if you take Russia,
Moscow was always the religious
core.
Nicholas II just hated Moscow,
it represented all those values
that he thought were Russian,
but St.
Petersburg,
Petrograd--Leningrad became a
major, major city and because of
the residence of the czar that's
where it was.
Or, if you take almost anywhere
else--the Austro-Hungarian
Empire, before it broke up,
Vienna was now this over-sized
capital that--in a very,
very small country,
but it was balanced off by
Budapest.
In Italy, obviously,
Milan and Turin were terribly
important cities,
and Rome,
which is just sort of a sleepy,
ecclesiastical capital full of
tourists and clergy.
But France is unique.
The role of Paris in French
life is unique and that has been
accentuated over the centuries,
particularly the last century
and a half, by some of the
things that I want to talk
about.
In 1947, about,
there was a book called
Paris and the French
Desert that looked at this
sort of unusual thing,
that where else but in France
would, then, ninety-seven
percent of the population be
considered provincials in a very
derogatory,
a very pejorative sense,
and Paris would be the place
that all of the Rastignacs of
France would try to go,
because of the economic,
political, social and cultural
domination of the capital.
A Rastignac was--it was before
this course, but was the central
figure, or one of them,
in Balzac's novel Old
Goriot, Père
Goriot, and he's a sort of a
somewhat poor noble from the
Charente in the west of France
who's going to hit the big time,
and wants to sleep with all the
right ladies and become wealthy
without doing any work,
and he became sort of a symbol
for this aggressive,
provincial, in this case a sort
of poor noble who has to get to
Paris to make the big time,
because the big time could only
be there.
Now, I mean in almost any
domain you can think of--one
exception, this is not the time
for me to talk about it,
though I would love to do that,
is gastronomy,
because although Lyon is
considered--Lyon is not the
capital of any region,
it was the second most
important city in France,
and still is,
even though it's slightly
smaller now than Marseille,
if you just count the city.
Lyon became the capital of
French gastronomy and not Paris;
but, that's almost the
exception.
And, one of the reasons why the
role of the dominance of Paris
is so great is precisely because
of the centralization of the
French state.
In my memory,
as a young guy hanging out and
drinking a cheap wine in Paris
when I was doing my thesis,
you could only hear on the news
people with Parisian accents,
giving the news--only.
And then, before the news they
had this little thing they
called Actualité
Régionale,
where if you lived in Auvergne
there would be--you would have a
fifteen minute program talking
about local events and you might
have somebody who had an
Auvergnat accent;
or, if you lived in Marseille
or in Nice you might have
somebody with a southern accent
giving the news about local
schools,
and having pictures of young
women presenting flowers to some
corrupt politician,
and it would be like that.
But, basically,
the news was always given by
people with a northern accent,
either a Loire Valley accent,
and they're very proud,
they think they speak the best
French, but a Parisian accent.
But, that's all changed,
but the reality of the
situation, that Paris is overly
dominant, has not changed at
all.
And Balzac, to go back to
Balzac, he put it the way
Parisians view the provinces,
and this is still the case.
He described provincials as
being dominated by routine and
monotony in their small towns,
that they're all the same,
he wrote, which is obviously
not the case.
He says, "provincials are like
mold, burrowing in their little
plots, or frogs at the bottom of
their puddles,
engaged in sordid,
trivial rivalries,
moved by petty jealousies,
avarice and material interests.
Since they do not think about
the things that are serious,
they get excited by tiny
things."
Now, you used to have--there
was a very famous cover of
The New Yorker in which
you had a map of the United
States as seen from New York,
and where you had New York,
and then you had this sort of
large ditch that finally--then,
Los Angeles was half a football
throw away, and everything in
the middle was just sort of
desert,
basically.
And, certainly,
the way that provincial
people--including myself,
and we're legally residents of
France,
and we live in Ardeche and I'm
proud of it--view Parisians is
often with that same kind of
contempt that the Parisians look
at us.
And, I mean,
for example in France--and if
this ever disappears I'm going
to be one unhappy guy--the
license plates,
the last numbers of the license
plate tells you where people are
from.
So, if you have a sixty-one
you're from the Ain,
and if you have a sixty-two
you're from the Pas-de-Calais,
or if you have a sixty-three
you're from the
Puy-de-Dôme.
And you can amuse yourself as
you're driving along,
saying, "well,
that guy from Châteauroux
is off to visit his cousin in
Besançon."
That's the way I get by driving
long rides;
but, during the vacation
seasons in July and August,
when all of us down here are
inundated with tourists,
when people see those
seventy-fives,
which is the license plate for
Paris or--and this is not on the
test--or,
if they see seventy-seven,
seventy-eights,
ninety-one, ninety-two,
ninety-three,
ninety-four,
ninety-five,
they know it's Paris,
in the Paris region,
and they know that there'll be
certain expectations,
often condescending
expectations,
that will be in the way that
Parisians and people from the
la region parisienne
present themselves
vis-à-vis we poor
struggling frogs in our little
ponds.
Now, that has changed, for sure;
but, the centralization of the
French government and the
domination of Paris over the
life of the nation is very
difficult to change,
over a long period of time.
Now, and I guess one of the key
kind of indicators of what's
going on in terms of economics,
the dominance of the Paris
region in terms of the economy,
is that Lyon,
which was always France's
second city,
first in gastronomy,
as I said earlier,
that the Bank of Lyon,
the Crédit
Lyonnais,
that is, the Lyon Bank,
in the 1860s moves its
headquarters to Paris and not in
Lyon,
as if it's sort of given up.
And, people,
for example,
who follow the Lyon opera
always say, "well,
our opera is fine but it's
nothing,
of course, like Paris,
where all the resources are
poured into Paris."
How did it get this way?
Just thinking over the long
run, how did France end up so
centralized?
All states centralized,
became larger and centralized
their ability to extract
resources from their population.
If you take Europe in 1500,
the year 1500,
there were about 1500
territorial states and they
ranged from big,
consolidated monarchies like
Spain and England and France to
bishoprics such as Trier,
in Germany, that were hardly
bigger than the gardens of the
archbishops who ran them.
But, over a long period of
time, state-making is one of the
essential processes in European
history,
the creational of more powerful
monarchical states and
eventually of national states
with a variety of political
outcomes--the unification of
Italy,
to the extent Italy's ever been
unified, the unification of
Germany in 1871,
and Italy in the 1850s and '60s.
But, in the case of France,
if you go to the sixteenth
century, if you go to these
chateaux around the Loire,
and you see all of the
beautiful furniture that's been
made by skilled artisans,
one you always see is you see
this big case with handles on
it, and they were--that's where
the king's documents and the
Minister--well,
le Garde des Sceaux,
the Chief Financial Officer and
Justice Officer,
where all their papers were,
because the monarchy really
didn't have a capital.
The monarchy was wherever the
king was.
And it's in the sixteenth
century that Paris becomes the
capital.
Paris is not in the middle of
France, as you can clearly see,
but you're not going to have a
capital in Montluçon or
something like that.
And, so, you have the kings
there;
and the whole process of
absolutism, which you don't have
to know about.
But, it's in the seventeenth
century that European rulers
expand their power
vis-à-vis their enemies,
land-grabbing-- that's how
France ends up with Alsace--and,
as I said before,
increasing their ability to
extract resources,
that is to take money from very
ordinary people.
And, so, Louis XIV,
who liked to call himself the
Sun God, a modest megalomaniac,
he sends out officials into the
provinces to enforce his will,
and these dudes are called
intendents--but that doesn't
matter,
you don't have to remember that.
But, they are out there and
they go through a process of
negotiation with local elites,
with nobles and with law
courts;
but, in the end,
the only thing that matters is
that this increases the power of
the state,
that it's during the period of
absolute monarchy that armies
become enormous.
And, if you travel around
France, you'll see all the
fortifications of Vauban,
who was a military genius,
Vauban, and fortresses,
Papillion, and along the
Pyrénées there and
up in Lille;
and up along here you'll see
these fabulous fortresses,
and these fortresses had to be
maintained by people who were
going to test the guns,
the canons, to make sure they
worked, and to be there all the
time;
and, thus you have this
enormous increase in standing
armies.
Now, and then here comes the
French Revolution,
and what does the French
Revolution want to do?
Well, it wants to rationalize
the administration of France--it
wants to do other things,
too, but that's not this
course.
And, so, instead of having
where before you had something
like one-hundred tolls you had
to pay on the Loire River,
if you're transporting some
goods, they eliminate all those
tolls, they try to create
uniformed weights and measures,
and that'll take one-hundred
years before that really works.
But, what they do is they
increase the power of the
center, of the government.
And, in order--because their
arch-enemies are the nobles,
who are high-tailing it toward
Germany,
and toward England and
everywhere else,
and trying to launch wars
against the revolution--what
they say is,
"we will undercut the authority
of the church and the nobles in
the provinces by creating what
they call departments,
départements."
And, so, they create the
departments that become part of
this administrative system,
so that every department--and
this sounds boring but it's
actually interesting--every
département in
France,
most of them are named after
rivers, and some after mountains
or proximity to the sea,
will have the same officials,
and that these strings that
reach out into now ninety-five
departments in France,
including Corsica,
all lead to Paris.
And, that where someone once
said that Gaul was divided into
three parts, now what happens is
people living in any region in
France,
the three parts that they see
are the Ministry of Justice,
the Ministry of War,
and the Ministry of the
Interior.
So, you have these
départements,
and these are created in 1790,
and they still exist.
The only big change came in
1960 when they consolidated the
ones around Paris,
because of the growth of the
Paris region,
as you can see there.
So, if you take number one--but
we don't have to go through them
all and I assure you we
won't--if you take number one,
the Ain, a-i-n,
it's named after a river;
or if you take number two,
the Aisne, a-i-s-n-e,
it's named after a river;
and how many hundreds of
thousands of people died along
there in World War One;
or, you take number three,
the same thing,
Allier.
They're named after rivers and
they don't all--they're not all
the same size.
The biggest physically is
Dordogne, which has probably
grown because so many British
live there, something like 8,000
full-time residents.
I'm pointing toward the
Charonne, that doesn't do any
good, but anyway--because,
when I get close sometimes I
can't see.
And, then, the smallest is the
Pyrén&eac
ute;es-Orientales;
Roussillon, which is French
Catalonia.
That doesn't matter.
The point is that the
revolution, in order to defeat
its enemies, further centralizes
the state,
and then along comes the little
corporal, the little general,
the little megalomaniac,
Napoleon, N One.
And, he of course pushes
centralization even further,
where he liked to brag--it's
one of these famous lines you
find in textbooks,
but--that he could look at his
watch and see what all the kids
in the lycées that
he'd created,
the high schools,
were studying at any one time.
And he makes state
centralization even more
important.
And, then, in the Second
Empire, 1852/1870,
his nephew, who some wag once
called the hat without the head,
Napoleon III,
what he does is he uses
centralization as a tool of the
state to consolidate his own
power and that of the Empire,
and that is to undercut the
residual influence of the
nobility.
If you wanted something,
and this is still true in
France today,
it doesn't do any good to go to
the local notable,
like you did in the eighteenth
century and say,
"hey, monsieur,
the little guy,
it would be great if we had a
school."
It doesn't do any good at all,
and he realizes that.
And, so, the patronage of the
Empire is that he can provide
railroads, he can provide money
for things, and that further
centralizes the state.
And, so, you've got these
processes in the nineteenth
century, economic processes that
you find all over Europe that
consolidate the power of the
French State,
centralized in Paris.
Railroads is a good
example--and sometimes I'll
throw out examples,
you're not responsible for
them,
it's just kind of hopefully
interesting for you to think
about.
If you think of two towns down
here, Brive, b-r-i-v-e,
famous for its rugby,
and Tulle, t-u-l-l-e,
which is a capital.
I mentioned it the first day
because that's where lots of
people were hung.
They were the same size in the
1850s, but Brive gets the
railroad and not Tulle,
the railroad from Paris.
And, so, that centralization
is--also there are mountains
there, it's easier to build in
Brive.
But, the state can make or
break regions with their
economic patronage.
And one of the reasons why
France ends up with a republic,
and not a monarchy,
is because these prefects who
represent the Republic can go
into conservative regions and
say,
"hey, we didn't really like the
way the elections came out last
time;
your municipal council,
uh-uh-uh, a lot of monarchists
there.
You would like a bridge across
your river, wouldn't you?"
And that was the case in our
village because there wasn't a
bridge across the river,
and there was a little boat
would take people across this
awesome, swirling,
dangerous river.
And, you want your bridge,
well, let's see how the
elections go next time.
The State can provide these
services.
And the evolution of banking in
the nineteenth century further
consolidates power.
There was sort of an economic
takeoff in the 1850s and '60s in
Paris because the State banks
are in Paris,
the State financial
institutions are in Paris,
and they can make or break
investment in all these places.
Now, the railroad,
even in our day,
maybe not in your day but
in--well, yes,
still in your day.
I was on the TGV the third day
it opened which was--it opened
on September twenty-eighth,
1981, and I was there on
September^( )thirtieth,
taking a trip to Lyon,
though it only went fast when
it really got to a certain point
here.
Now, but the railroads,
if you look at the map of the
railroads in France,
at any time you want including
now,
all roads lead--all tracks lead
to Paris.
So, for example,
now if you want to go from--say
you're in Lyon and you want to
go to Bordeaux,
you're going to be broke.
The reason--unless you can take
about eight hours to do
it--because, the way you're
going to do it is you're going
to take a train that goes one
hour and fifty-eight minutes to
Paris,
and then you're going to take
another train that zips down
here in about four hours to
Bordeaux,
but you're paying by kilometer.
So, it's going to be terribly
expensive.
When I was commuting between
Limoges and Paris,
that was still a long trip
then, there was no TGV;
it was about four hours.
And, when I once took the train
over to Poitiers,
it took three hours,
because if you go across the
lines it's not good.
Now, how do trains--?
An obvious reason how trains
reinforce the predominance of
Paris.
Take my business,
the teaching profession,
is that the domination of Paris
is such that you have this
phenomenon in France,
which they still call it
that--they call it
turbo-prof;
and a turbo train was a
fast train before the TGV,
the first ones went to Normandy
to carry the wealthy Parisians
to Dorvillier [ph?].
And a turbo-prof is
somebody who lives in Paris,
and whose dream is to teach at
Paris, particularly at Paris I.
French universities are named
very poetically,
Paris I, II,
III, IV, V, VI,
all the way through XIV,
which is a real hole,
or XIII is probably the worst.
But, the turbo-prof will
be somebody who is assigned to
Reims, and who takes the train
there every day,
or to Tours;
but to Lyon also since this is
only two hours,
this is four-hundred
kilometers.
Two hours, you can be on a damn
train to New York City and
you'll be lucky if you get
eighty miles in two hours,
or an hour and fifty minutes.
So, you've got people who live
in Lyon who teach in Paris;
or, friends of mine that teach
in Lille and live in Paris--or,
I teach in Rouen
frequently--who live in Paris in
teach in Rouen.
Now, this is bad because what
it does is sort of sucks local
university life out,
and it means that this
phenomenon of the
turbo-prof has been
accentuated by the fast
train--the fast train,
by the way I keep referring to
it, is called the TGV,
the Train à
Grand Vitesse,
because ça roule,
it goes fast.
So, the nineteenth century
accentuates all of this,
and the result is that still by
1947 when Gravier wrote this
book called Paris and the
French Desert--if you look
at an encyclopedia,
the definition of provincial,
somebody who's provincial,
was still provincial,
someone who is gauche,
and that's not politics,
who's kind of a bumpkin,
kind of a pluke,
kind of a day late and a dollar
short, who lacks the
distinction--I'm reading this
right out of the Larousse
dictionary.
For example,
to have--to give the impression
of being provincial with--like
you just arrived at the train
from Brittany in Gare
Montparnasse,
and you're just so totally out
of it you can hardly find a
place to buy
crêpes,
and then that's all you want to
do, and you're sort of clueless.
And, so, the departments,
along with the railroads and
along with better roads also,
and the banking network,
increases the centralization of
the French State.
And, I can remember,
this is about twenty years ago,
but there was big
demonstrations from people in
Brittany because of--there's
always these boats crashing
ashore,
and oil slicks all over the
Breton coast;
or, people that produce
artichokes, the price of
artichokes, because of the
méventes,
the prices are so low there
that they're always rushing down
to the prefecture and dumping
artichokes in the prefecture and
protesting.
And, I remember there's one
amazing photo from the Place de
la Concord, which is a big place
in Paris,
a big square,
where you've got these Breton
mayors who are wearing their
sashes,
their tricolor sashes,
red, white and blue,
and the police are using--the
CRS,
which are the military police;
they're a little less vicious
than they used to be,
but I was in a demonstration
against Sarkozy in mid-May,
and the police were,
the CRS, which is sort of carte
blanche now, were fairly
aggressive.
But, anyway,
these police were wrestling to
the ground these mayors who were
protesting,
using their tri-color sashes,
threatening to strangle them
with their own sashes of their
authority.
Only in France would this be
possible.
And, so, every government that
comes to power,
they say, well we're going to
do something about this.
De Gaulle said let--no he
didn't really say that,
it was Mao--but,
"let the hundreds of thousands
of flowers bloom."
But De Gaulle,
who we'll talk about later,
De Gaulle said,
how in the hell can you run a
state in which there are
four-hundred and forty different
kinds of cheese?
There are a lot more than that.
And he believed that it was
insidious, in order to have
these sort of regional cultures.
I'll give you an example.
It was illegal--it's still
illegal in France to name a baby
a name that is not officially
approved, absolutely--or even to
adopt one.
There was a famous case in the
1970s or '80s,
there was a family called
Trognon,
and a trognon is a
cigarette butt,
and when they tried to adopt a
baby,
it would be called,
let's say Jean-Philippe
Trognon, they said,
"oh, no, that baby would be
damaged by having such a last
name;
you don't have the right to
adopt this baby."
And there were cases where
Bretons tried to name their
children Breton names and the
French State said,
uh-uh, pas possible,
because it wasn't officially
French.
Well, De Gaulle has been dead
for a very long time,
and there has been progress,
but what has not changed is
still the power in Paris,
in these ministries,
to dictate the life of schools,
of almost everything else.
And a lot of the strikes that
you see in high schools and
in--I better get to my lecture,
but--you see in high schools
and even in middle schools,
have to do with the State,
somebody saying,
well we're going to take away
two-hundred teachers in your
department,
or we're going to maintain a
curriculum that doesn't seem to
make any sense.
My son, when he was in
Seconde,
which is the first year of
French high school,
they were out blocking traffic
until some angry driver rolled
over the foot of a protestor and
then everybody kind of went off
and ate pizza.
But, these were reactions
against what the State was
trying to do.
Or, in the 1980s,
when there were huge
demonstrations by people
favoring the Catholic Church as
an institution vis-à-vis
education,
it was the same thing,
with reacting against the kind
of dictates or dictates
coming down from Paris.
And when Gambetta,
whom you can read about,
whom I mentioned the other day,
when he said,
"clericalism,
there's the enemy";
and, then you had this sort of
campaign against the church,
particularly the teaching
aspect of the church that's
fascinating,
which I'll talk about later.
So, France ends up like that.
Many people saw themselves as
administrés,
that is, people who were
administered,
who are governed,
but in the sense of having
people passing papers back and
forth,
and having to sign every damn
thing you could ever
imagine--it's just
unbelievable--before they ever
thought of themselves as being
citizens.
And, certainly there is no
other country in the
post-communist world in which so
many people work for the state.
Now, having said that,
let me just say as an
addendum--and this is my
opinion, you could ignore
it--that things work in France.
And, it used to be that twenty
or thirty years ago you'd say
nothing in France works,
and everything works in the
U.S, and now it's just the
opposite, totally the opposite.
And, if you're going to be
sick, and unless you're wealthy,
you're better off being sick in
France than you are here,
because the system really works
and there are abuses,
but the Social Security System
which encompasses more than just
what we mean by Social Security,
the secu,
which involves healthcare,
is one of those things that
really works,
as annoying as the whole
structure, and the taxes and all
of that.
And, of course,
the challenge--so this is the
latter part of the course--is
what do you do with this
and Europe?
Europe, which is going to erase
these license plates and are
going to take away part of what
it means to live in France.
And that's why I would've voted
against the Constitution,
I encouraged people to vote
and I know almost nobody,
except professors in Paris and
Lyon, who are for that
Constitution that was defeated a
year ago May^(
)twenty-ninth--so,
there.
Anyway, now,
how did this all happen that
given the fact in February of
1870 you had a Monarchist
dominated Assembly elected in
which rural regions,
particularly,
but not necessarily just
Brittany and Normandy and
Auvergne--these are big,
still Catholic regions,
as we'll see later,
that they wanted the
restoration of a monarchy.
Why does that not happen?
How does this country end up
being a Republic,
the Third Republic,
which has been castigated or
been denounced because it seemed
to fumble along?
But, it was the longest
republic and it lasts from,
depending on when you start
it--and you can read about
that--whether you start it in
1875 or 1877,
or when there really was a
Republic, the early '80s--it
lasts until May,
June 1940.
So, how did all that happen?
Now, here we move into a
history that is the kind of old
style history.
It's the story of decisions
taken by individual people.
There was a pretender to the
throne, and this man was--his
life got off to an interesting
start.
He was dubbed the "miracle
baby," for reasons that I will
explain.
The Comte de Chambord was a
Bourbon, he was part of the
Royal Family of--that was Louis
XIV,
and Louis XVI,
and in 1820 his father was
assassinated by a Liberal,
a man called Louvel,
and he's at the opera,
he gets kind of bored and he
walks out, they leave the opera,
and this guy Louvel comes up
and he stabs,
puts a knife right through him.
And, it was not just a random
act, he wanted to extinguish
this royal line.
And the Bourbons had been
restored in 1815 to 1830.
Again, this your old style
history.
So, France goes into great
mourning.
The church bells ring very,
very slowly,
all over the place,
because there is--the heir to
the French throne is dead.
And there's a huge campaign
against the Liberals,
because of that.
And then, lo and behold it
turns out that his widow,
to whom he confessed various
infidelities before expiring,
was pregnant;
indeed, he was the father.
They didn't run DNA tests or
anything, but he was the father.
And as France held its breath,
because they wanted a boy,
this miracle baby was born,
l'enfant du miracle.
And the unfortunate thing is
that he was sort of a sad sack,
un pauvre type.
It's tough being the pretender
to the throne,
the would-be Henri V,
and your name recognition is
such that in Royalist towns in
the West of France,
like Nantes,
that somebody in the middle of
the night would scribble
graffiti,
Long Live Henri V,
and that people would get
together in church on January^(
)twenty-first,
the date that Louis XVI was
executed, and they would pray
for the restoration of the
Bourbon throne.
But, there's also another
family of pretenders,
and that is the Orleanists,
the Orléanists,
but Orleanists--I just wrote it
there in English.
And these people--this is kind
of boring-- but these people
were in government between 1830
and 1848,
and King Louis-Philippe,
who was chased from the throne
in February of 1848,
was seen as progressive,
he was seen as the bourgeois
monarch but he was perfectly
noble.
He'd gone to Kentucky and drunk
lots of Bourbon once,
he carried an umbrella,
that sort of middle class
symbol of protection,
and he is chased from the
throne in 1848.
But, he'd helped modernize the
economy, and he did not restore
the church to its old power.
And the Orleanists were
extremely clever,
where Chambord was thick as a
brick,
and spent most of his time
telling anti-Semitic jokes and
playing cards with his cronies
in the Austrian capital,
or mountains near Vienna--or
maybe it was near Salzburg,
I guess it was near Salzburg,
the Orleanists had a bunch of
sons of Louis-Philippe who were
pretty clever.
One of them,
by the way, just about ten
years ago, the Orleanist family
suffered kind of an embarrassing
reversal when one of the
Orleanists,
sort of the third in line if
there was ever an Orleanist
restoration of the throne,
was arrested for burglary,
as being an accessory for
burglary in the Pyrén&eac
ute;es-Orientales.
But, anyway,
so when France collapsed after
the war, and when the Commune
comes along,
it seems to Royalists,
that is, the people who wanted
a restoration of the monarchy,
that their ship had come in.
So what's going to happen?
Now, it's easy to make fun of
Chambord, who was a pauvre
type, a sad sack,
in many ways.
But, the history of Royalism is
not--it goes beyond that,
and there was a strong Royalist
movement,
as I've already suggested,
and it wasn't just people
looking backwards.
Indeed, he said in his various
pronouncements written for him
by someone else that he didn't
want to be a king of the old
regime,
he did not want to turn the
clock back to 1788,
and that you could combine a
modernity with monarchy.
But, there was never any doubt
that if he was restored to the
throne that he would rule.
And you have to imagine him
after the commune,
after the slaughter and the
buildings are still burning,
or at least smoldering,
that he comes to Paris.
And he'd never,
rather like Louis-Napoleon,
had hardly ever been in Paris
before;
he really hadn't,
I don't think,
ever.
So, he gets a carriage,
he rents a carriage,
and he goes around as a
tourist,
and he goes to Notre Dame,
and he goes to Sainte-Chapelle,
and he goes to pay homage at
what they thought were the
remains of his departed
ancestors.
And he had bone fragments of
what they thought--or,
at least, ashes of Marie
Antoinette that he had with him
in his room all the time.
And, so, but it's not--he has
his entourage,
he has his posse,
he has his entourage.
But, there also are these
strong traditions of popular
Royalism, of ordinary people and
peasants who believe fervently
in the monarchy.
You found them in very odd
places.
There's a strong tradition in
Nîme, one of my favorite
places, of popular Royalism,
and also of course in
Brittany--I keep giving Breton
examples, I'll pick other ones.
So, and also because of the
close association of the
monarchy, and particularly the
Legitimists,
they're called Legitimists,
the Bourbons with the
church--you've got fertile
ground in areas that were still
practicing religion,
and we'll talk more about that
another time.
He makes clear that he is going
to restore the church to its,
what he considered rightful
place of privilege in France;
and, possibly,
he could benefit from the wave
of religious revival that occurs
in France in the 1870s.
Now, every time there's a big
time political disaster,
from the point of view of the
Catholic Church in France,
it's followed by a period of
religious revival.
After the French Revolution and
Napoleon, and Napoleon makes
peace with the church,
there is, all of a sudden,
a revival with people forming
religious confraternities,
of people paying to rebuild
churches that have been
vandalized during the
Revolution,
where they're melting down
church bells to use as cannon
and things like that.
The famous beautiful,
fabulous, fabulous Monastery
Church of Cluny is up near
Mâcon,
right here, had been destroyed
and they tried to--they restored
a couple of the remaining
towers.
And, as Chateaubriand said,
the writer, "I don't know what
we must believe but we must
believe in something," and he
gets down on his knees and
prays.
The same thing happens in the
1870s, there's a revival of that
old time religion,
and it's helped by various
miracles and that kind of thing,
but which I'll talk about in
the lecture on religion,
which is kind of fun--it's fun
to do.
And, for example,
when you go to any town or any
village in France you will see
what they call Mission Crosses.
You'll see these crosses that
are stone crosses.
The first ones were put up
during the counter-reformation,
or the Catholic reformation,
in the^( )seventeenth century,
to try to win back areas that
had become Protestant,
that is, around Lyon.
You find some that are put up,
not surprisingly,
after 1815, and the others are
in the 1860s or the 1870s,
and then never again.
And these are big crosses that
are put out, usually outside the
villages.
And, sometimes the crosses were
destroyed during the
revolutions--there was a huge
one in Reims destroyed in the
Revolution of 1830;
but, most of these crosses,
you can read them.
This is an iconography of
belief, and you can see the
dates because they'll put the
date, like 1868.
There's about ten of them in
our village.
Some of them there are just
little stumps left,
but it's kind of fun to walk
around and look at them;
but, here these proliferate
wildly, and so there'll be
missions.
And, I remember when I went to
Jesuit high school in Portland,
Oregon we had to have these
retreats or revivals,
and the priest would--these
missionaries would come in,
and for three days thunder at
you and then people would go off
and go to Confession;
and I didn't have much to
confess, I often wish I had had.
But, in those days in high
school-- but anyway,
there we go--you'd go and do
these things,
and it would be a big sort of
public spectacle,
a spectacle.
And, so, Henri V could
capitalize on that because there
were lots of people that would
be very happy to see him come
back because of their belief.
But, it's hard,
if you're fourty-seven years,
your job is a pretender to the
throne, it's difficult.
He had a hard time getting
around.
He'd had a very royal accident,
he'd broken his leg falling off
a horse, and he had a terrible
limp.
And, also, because he just sat
around and played cards all the
time and ate and drank,
he became quite a large man,
and occasionally he would get
up and go and look at the relics
of Marie Antoinette,
and then he'd go back and play
cards for big stakes;
he was a big-time gambler.
Because he wasn't a very good
card player his posse took him
for fairly sizable amounts of
money.
But, he viewed "hereditary
monarchy" as the unique port of
salvation--that's a very
religious image--that could save
France.
And he talked about strong
authority underplaying judicious
liberty, for example.
And the key to his strength,
besides the church,
are the nobles.
Now, having a noble title
didn't do a hell of a lot of
good after the French
Revolution,
and it's easy to give this sort
of stereotype of nobles as being
just letting their nails grow
very long and drinking nice
wines and chasing each other's
mistresses and wives around the
gardens,
in Versailles or anywhere else.
In fact, many nobles became
chairmen of the boards of
various companies,
and they still had these
atavisms,
these throwbacks to the old
regime where it was said near
Toulouse that if the noble
announced after mass that it'd
be good to have a little
firewood,
that he could look out from the
ponderosa and see peasants,
obedient peasants carrying
large stacks of wood up to the
big house;
and, maybe they'd get a little
something on Easter from the big
guy.
But, basically the State was
winning the battle against the
nobles, and you could still be
the Count of anywhere,
or the Duke of anywhere,
and you can't mobilize goodies
to give to local people except
on a very local scale.
And the state is winning out.
Now, Gambetta,
who was a smart guy who dies
very young, he said that France
became a republic because most
of the people wanted a republic
and they didn't want a monarchy,
and that's all there was to it.
And the elections in the early
1880s would certainly make this
clear.
Now, there was even a group of
nobles who believed that they
could be elected,
that if you had an election
people would actually vote to
restore the monarchy.
These were kind of the popular
royalists of places like
Nîmes.
By the way, I should write
these things down,
Nîme.
See, in the old regime there
would've been an "s" there,
and that's why you've got this
little chapeau up there.
Anyway, but that wasn't going
to happen because most people in
France ultimately did not want a
monarchy.
But, what about old Chambord?
When disaster came he was not
ready.
He issued poorly constructed
manifestos in order to espouse,
quote, "the freedom of the
church as the prime condition of
the peace of spirit and order in
the world,
and to protect the Pope with
the honor of our country in the
most incontestable cause of its
glory among nations,"
et cetera, et cetera.
But, there was a big problem,
that for all of his failings,
human failings,
and there were indeed many,
and his intellectual
limitations which were daunting,
he was a man of faith and
loyalty to his principles,
for better or for worse,
in this context.
And, in 1789 when the
Revolution came and then
executed old Louis XVI,
the white flag of the Bourbons,
plain white flag of the
Bourbons, sometimes with a
fleur-de-lys on it,
and all that,
was replaced by the red,
white and blue flag,
the three colored flag,
the tricolore,
which was a combination of
adding the color white for the
Bourbons in 1789,
to the red and blue that were
the colors of Paris,
of the city of Paris.
And, in the end he refused to
compromise when his advisors
say, look, we can pull this off
if you agree to accept the three
colored flag of revolution,
of the French Revolution,
which had killed his family
members;
and, he refused to do that.
And they tried to make a deal
with the Orleanists,
and the Orleanists produced
children, one after another.
But Chambord had no children.
And, so, upon his death who is
going to follow him,
if he's going to be king?
And, so, they proposed a deal,
why don't you be king until you
croak-- they didn't put it quite
like that--and then the
Orleanists will take over with
the red,
white and blue flag?
And he said,
to his credit,
"no, without my principles I am
just"--as he put it rather
indelicately and cruelly about
himself--"a fat man with a big
limp."
And he went back to his castle,
anti-Semitic jokes and
card-playing buddies.
And, so, France lurched into a
period called The Moral Order,
the Republic of the Moral
Order.
You can read the details of
this, which are not fascinating,
but we'll get through this and
move onto more interesting
things.
In 1875 there's an amendment to
the Constitution that
essentially--voted by one vote,
or approved by one vote,
by the Assembly--that
essentially transforms France
into a Republic.
In 1877 a general called
Mac-Mahon, who had fought in the
1870/71 war--you may think that
that's not a very French name;
there's a strong Irish
influence around Bordeaux.
In fact, one of the great
Bordeaux wines is called Lynge
Barge, lynge as in lynch,
which is an Irish name.
But, Mac-Mahon was French,
and that he is a general and
becomes president of the State,
and he tries in 1877,
on the sixteenth of^( )May,
to overthrow the government,
and basically a question of
responsibility to whom--it's not
interesting--he fails to do
that,
and France in the early 1880s,
you have this sort of rooting
of the Republic,
and a rooting of the Republic
because most people in France
wanted one.
It seemed to be the regime that
divided France least,
what Gambetta called the
nouvelles couches,
or the new social strata,
the new social strata,
the middle classes,
the petty bourgeois.
Workers obviously didn't want a
monarchy;
but, in many areas of France,
particularly in the south,
lots of peasants did want a
republic, and France becomes a
republic.
And, this republic is strongly
identified with Paris,
and if, because of the fear of
Caesarism,
the fear of another Napoleon,
or another Robespierre before
that, or another Napoleon III,
they create executive authority
that's extremely weak.
Power is in the Chamber of
Deputies, in the Assembly,
and the President is a
convener;
he tries to get people to do
the right things,
and it's a political club.
They all tutoyer each
other, even if they hate each
other's politics,
and they call each other by the
informal name.
And, even though it's
decentralized,
it does not mean that the State
is not strong,
and that the State will not be
making decisions that will
affect the lives of ordinary
people.
And the most controversial of
those decisions will ultimately
be in 1905--if you exclude going
to war and getting all these
millions of people killed--was
the separation of church and
state.
And, that is the work of a
strongly centralized government,
centered in Paris,
as I've said over and over
again, but imposing its will,
for better or for worse,
on the provinces;
and, in doing so,
following train tracks,
following the roads,
following these centralized
sort of vines,
going out from Paris into the
provinces, as a way of exerting
its will, its influence,
and its patronage.
And, in conclusion,
the state becomes the new ways
that patronage,
economic, financial,
cultural, political,
is dispensed.
It replaces the nobility,
the local nobles,
it replaces the church,
and it replaces the monarchy
that most people in France did
not want.
Next time let's talk about
identity, and let's talk about
one of my favorite topics,
the role of the schools in
towns and in villages.
See ya.